une
alors
autrefois la galette était le plat du
pauvre en bretagne et on en mangeait
beaucoup
autrefois le blé noir le célèbre
sarrazin tant chantée par nos poètes le
blé noir poussé bien la terre était
pauvre et on se contentait de rendement
dérisoire maintenant on déguste encore
des galettes plus dans les villes fait
dans les campagnes d'ailleurs monsieur
pas skié avec quoi c'est ton la galette
et du blé noir et qu'est ce qu'il ya
comme autres ingrédients ont bien eu une
sale et de l'eau sur devant on trouve
dans certaines crêperie je crois des
gens qui ne se contente pas de mettre du
blé noir qui ajoute autre choix ils
mettent du la farine de blé d'orge
c'est mieux mais c'est moi j'ai et aux
touristes ils savent que s'ils avaient
la voie du christ ayant aussi vous tous
ici son origine bretagne manger des
graines et puis c'est quand même elle
aussi a demandé n'est pas tellement cher
naturelles ou dans les terres en vues
puis examen de consommer de mannequin ne
se dégrade continuellement sa vraie
billets le soir ils m'ont jamais tant
pour l'approvisionnement en blé noir
est-ce que vous avez des difficultés
parce que le blé noir on en fait quand
même de moins en moins en bretagne
nous on apprend difficulté
on veut bien répondre toujours et vous
n'êtes pas le seul à ignorer la
provenance du blé noir
pourtant il en faut de plus en plus pour
alimenter les moulins qui comme celui ci
donneront de cette farine qui sent bon
la simplicité et le naturel et pour vous
qui mangent et peut-être des galettes en
ce vendredi soir
vous pensiez vous que pousse le blé noir
en bretagne
et bien détrompez vous le sarrasin est
devenu fais nous une pièce de musée en
clair on entoure plus pourtant on
consomme sans doute autant de galettes
dans les quelques 2000 très prix de
bretagne
il y a aussi du sarrasin en auvergne à
l'étranger canada pologne afrique du sud
et cetera
mais ici il faut le chercher derrière
l'écran opaque des champs de maïs
parlons chiffres en quinze ans on est
passé de 260 mille quintaux à 8000 cette
très faible production régionale ne
serait certes pas suffire à alimenter
les moulins breton absolument pas on
obligé d'importer du canadien
afrique de sud
il faut pas avoir assez sur place et est
ce que dans les années à venir vous
allez toujours pouvoir importer du
canada ou d'afrique du sud ou d'ailleurs
ben je pense qu'on pourra tout au moins
se ravitailler sur lot de région
puisqu'on en finance ou le monde entier
on ne trouvera sans doute à l'étranger
mais les gerbes de blé noir ne feront
plus partie de notre paysage
on en parlera peut-être le soir en
mangeant des galettes canadienne ou
polonaises actuellement on ne cultive
plus le sarrasin on se contente de s'en
servir pour occuper le sol et les
experts vous diront qu'on ne peut rien
faire d'autre
revenons sur les productions en bretagne
le principal consommateur de galettes et
l'ille-et-vilaine
c'est également le département où on
cultive le plus de blé noir
viennent ensuite le morbihan est loin
derrière les côtes du nord est le
finistère chérèque est ce qu'on cultive
beaucoup de baignoire dans la région de
ploërmel
ah non pas tellement vous cette année
vous en avez fait pourquoi new c'est à
cause du remembrement
il y avait des tiers qui était qui était
resté en friche doute l'état lui ont
gentiment n'en fait pas
et cultiver du blé noir ça vous permet
d'améliorer la terre j'avais tellement
mal en ce moment ça nettoie les
mauvaises herbes
monsieur michel pourquoi ne fait-on plus
de blé n'ont pas de fait on crie on en
fait encore mouche noire mais la plupart
du temps on crée visé noir soit sur des
terres où on ne peut pas ouvrir d'autres
récoltes soit comme ici après armelle
s'établit en effet à dormans tour un
petit peu nettoyer certains emplacements
de saluer vitesse en friche qu'on vient
de récupérer dans traduire manquements
il faudrait obtenir des rendements d'au
moins 15 quintaux à l'hectare pour que
la culture du sahara zad devienne
rentable actuellement les rendements
moyens se situent entre 7 et 10 quintaux
par hectare inutile dans ce cas de
penser au remplacement de ces batteuse
qui souffre encore de l'effort et du
travail bien fait
et pensez vous que si tout le monde
arrête de faire du blé noir
on va encore pouvoir voir tous des
galettes non franchement donc légale est
c'est fini c'est fini on en sera plus du
tout en bretagne d'ici quelques années
ça m'étonnerait qu'on en trouve plus
court alors les galettes bretonnes
seront faites avec du blé noir du canada
oui ils resteront bretonne quand même
près égales et y restera bretonne
canadienne polonais mais la galette
restera donc bretonne sera t-elle
toujours d'aussi bonne qualité
va-t-on devoir à couvrir les sols si on
veut continuer à déguster ce plat port
deviendra t'il mets de luxe qui sait ni
vous ni moi je sais seulement que le blé
noir était une spécialité de chez nous
et que les galettes sur toujours
délicieuse chez ceux qui ne triche pas